[Applause]
[Music]
happy friday my magical friends in tv
land what a great show we have in store
for you
look who's here
dana perrino
yeah her new puppy percy has been on the
channel so much you'd think he's got a
book out
i wonder what percy could be thinking
i love my mom but i really just want to
stay home and chew on stuff behind your
back if i would have known i was going
to get dragged around all day i would
have stayed with that homeless guy at
least he sticks to one corner
also cat's here
it's friday uh so you know what that
means for one hour your medicine cabinet
is safe
now tonight's monologue is surprise
about the media and get this the angle
is how stupid they are
i'm nothing if not unpredictable
but their stupidity is so rich joe biden
wants to tax it case in point check out
this tweet from this lonely hack from
the daily beast who pretended a joke
question i did on the 5 was actually
real it was a parody multiple choice
question where i ask is joe biden a
racist with blood on his hands
the answer's a yes
b of course
c a and b
d
all of the above
now if you can't see that it's a joke
the view is looking for a new cast
member and you should audition
immediately
anyway this is his idiocy snagged in
another sucker brian class a professor
who tweets i've lived in several
authoritarian regimes and this is more
blatant and over the top than many of
the state media propaganda networks in
those countries
way to humble brag about living in
canada
but you know he's right it was blatant
and over the top which is usually a sign
that it's a joke you dumbass
here's another lefty with stage four
cancer of the funny bone these people
couldn't spell funny if you gave them
the fu
[Laughter]
anyway that guy is a columnist for the
washington post so no wonder he couldn't
tell the difference between parody and
reality when lefties spend all their
time around other lefties they don't
need to they just agree with their own
feverish fantasies and there's no one
there to apply the breaks here's a
huffington post headline
fox news jokey joe biden graphic isn't
funny at all
greg gutfeld introduced a mock survey
question on the five
that went too far
[Laughter]
yes it went too far
says a listicle junk site that spends
endless space labeling half of america
bigots and murderers
my phony quiz directly mocked their
hysteria but it flew over their heads
like dana trying to field a ground ball
[Laughter]
because it's on the ground
over her head
but this clueless this is not a bug in
the system it's the system itself for
example have you noticed how the media
is handling the justice millette case
it's getting less coverage than brian
stelter wearing a speedo
i want that image in your head all
weekend apparently there's taper
smellette doing a dry run of the hoax
hell he didn't rehearse that much for an
episode of empire
but that's big news and you'll only hear
about it here and why is that it's
because how can you revisit a story that
already already made you look like an
ass
this is a horrible story no matter what
kind of uh attack or crime it was but so
shaken by the story i forgot uh i know
he walked himself to the hospital do we
know how he is now i don't believe jesse
is making this up i don't like that it's
being put out there in the media that
this is a
possible fake cry i think that even sows
a seed that makes people feel like well
is he making this up or what is this
about right i don't like that and the
media has really cast so much doubt on
his story which i find so personally
offensive that a gay black man is
targeted and then suddenly he becomes
the victim of people's disbelief he said
his attackers hurled racial and
homophobic slurs at him
this is america in 2019.
that's america in 2019
if you work at cnn
it's not america it's not america at all
it's amazing they all fell for smilet
the way dana fell for david hasselhoff
in the 80s
very very hard
and they continue to distort the case
tonight on the chess news network
[Music]
peter pan here for the chess news
network david b rooks has been suspended
for reporting the truth we're outside
the trial of jesse smallett hoping to
talk to somebody from the inside oh it
looks like one of the jurors is here now
sir sister as one of the jurors how
racist is the jury i'm not a juror oh
one of the jurors hiding their identity
so how long have you been a white
supremacist
dude
so just the judge then i get it wait
okay so how incredible of an actor is
jesse smallett i don't know i'm not
familiar have you seen mighty ducks oh
he is pretty good in that right okay so
this case involves a noose do you think
we're gonna have a hung jury
you're an idiot get away it's pronounced
journalist
the latest from the trial back to you
odin thank you all right
gotta be honest it's tough to come back
from such fake news and then report the
real story because then you have to
admit how stupid you are reporting the
fake news the media should call in sick
on april fool's day
so the press is now like all your
relatives who voted for biden because
they said trump was the worst president
in history and now lately they just
don't want to talk politics that daily
beast tweet is an analogy for the
media's embrace of all things fake
because they want it so bad to be true
it's how i got catfished by that guy
pretending to be dr oz
to think i let him examine me
in a van
didn't call and because they live in a
bubble no one will tell them how dumb
they are so they continue falling for
the jokes and the hoaxes remember how
trump overfed those fish at the koi pod
remember him injecting bleach remember
the fine people hoax the dossier
remember how trump kissed a baby while
campaigning then proceeded to punt the
brat into the crowd
i made that one up because we know the
media would still find it believable
yeah all these were manufactured
phantoms that the media amplified
then when it turned out they were wrong
their memory is suddenly worse than joe
biden's
it's why they can't cover the biggest
stories like emails on hunter's laptop
the sitting president was laundering
corruption from our largest enemy
through his son and we have texts emails
photos and suddenly they're not curious
because they went out of their way to
pretend that story didn't exist
in order to win an election they said
smilette was real before they checked
they thought andrew cuomo was god before
they checked they said hunter's laptop
was fake before they checked they do
less due diligence than cat on tinder
marriage hasn't slowed her down
and because they get so much wrong
eventually they won't be able to comment
on anything that reminds us of their
wrongness pretty soon all you're going
to hear on cnn is crickets
oh the crunch
good that was nice see it's easy to
track all of their mistakes you just
look at the stories not being reported
those are the big stories they got wrong
before and so they intentionally misread
things knowing they can get away with it
so just to check that you're all
listening i leave you with a final
question
does the media intentionally avoid big
stories because it exposes their
incompetence and corruption
a
yes
b
of course
c
a and b
d
all of the above
note to the daily beast that question
not a joke
let's welcome tonight's guest
her last name's italian for i can't
reach the top shelf america's newsroom
co-anchor and co-host of the five
when voters want to turn right they head
west texas gop candidate for governor
alan west
he's the king of tech who's given the
woke
author of the book woke inc vivek
ramaswamy
[Applause]
and finally for christmas all she wants
is world peace and vicodin lots and lots
of vicodin buster's contributor cat tip
dana so the chart i did was actual
parody but then the dccc
which is what is that it's the
democratic congressional campaign
committee so they're in charge of
getting rep democrats elected to the
house yes so they did a chart to show
you how
gas prices under biden have dropped do
we have that
yes it's quite the remarkable twist of
facts here in fact they lost everybody
on this including the washington post
basically they made the y-axis so long
to make it look like two cents
it was a really big drop you see that
and like the statisticians and no nobody
could even believe this so if you're a
democrat right now and you're thinking
you want joe biden to win re-election
and you have allies like these you might
need to rethink something it's good so
this massive line you're seeing this
massive line you're seeing going down
like this is from like
one cent to two
cents that's what they did yeah amazing
anyway i don't know what the point was
but i'd like to see that's taken
seriously the other thing is but there
was maddie iglesias had written this
tweet about how biden had solved
everything and he was being sarcastic
they didn't realize it was being
sarcastic because then the gd triple c
is like well he actually has done
something the gas prices have gone down
if you look at the y axis
amazing
alan west running for governor awesome
that's great
so
in this monologue i keep trying i i
think i figured it out like how can the
media report on a story if the story is
a source of their constant embarrassment
because then they always have to create
the context like hey we were wrong so is
this this could be the reason why we get
so much fake news well without a doubt
and i think the thing is they continue
to be what i call a self-licking ice
cream cone where you know they have to
continue to put out there this bad news
these fake news stories and what have
you and then when they do get confronted
with truth or even when they do get
confronted with parody like what you
just talked about or when you read the
babylon b yeah i mean there's so many
times that they refer back to the
babylon b and they say well maybe this
was a real story yeah i mean they have
completely lost all sense of reality and
all sense of humor whatsoever but they
must come to understand they're now the
target of our humor yeah exactly it's a
nice reversal the dean wermer effect i
used to call it vivek i want to bring
you in on the woke angle that the reason
this is why i think wokism still exists
among journalists because it's a safe
area to do reporting for them like as
long as they just play woke they could
ignore all the other news yeah but there
is no way to be woke and be funny at the
same time right i think we were talking
about this before you know liberals used
to be funny liberals used to be funnier
than conservatives because the funny
side is the side that is able to talk
about everything and conservatives may
have been prudish and they said oh we
can't talk about this or that they
weren't the funny side now what woken
has done to liberalism is actually made
liberals the side that have certain
things they can't say or they can't talk
about and you can't be funny when you
have limits and not only can't you be
funny you apparently can't even get
jokes on the other side so that's why
you know conservative comedians i think
are going to be funnier going forward
yeah and it's it's that's when you
suddenly see the huffington post saying
he's gone too far
that chart he did that's gone too far
cats do you have sympathy at all for the
people that are paid to watch our show
like that have to like find things and
put them out of context i always wonder
what that's like the people that are
doing this like they got to catch you
catch me or catch dana doing something
awful it's easy with her because she's
got a mind in the gutter
she swears like a truck driver
on amphetamines it's really disgusting i
don't even know how the five stays
afloat to be honest
all right you done yeah
[Laughter]
there was a question buried in that yeah
i think so
uh somewhere
i look it's interesting because they do
have to take things out of context you
notice how the clip caught off right
before jessica responds
making it clear she sees it as a joke
and joking along with you
so
what's truly disgusting making a joke or
purposely twisting what was a joke to
try and destroy another person yeah that
you've never met yeah and i but i did
have fun reading all the replies i mean
they really were great like someone was
like c and d are the same
i'm like no
a b c and d are the same which is the
joke and then someone else was like it's
a joke and then someone replied to them
saying that's what a puppy murderer
would say
people and these were like real people
with their faces and names on their
accounts and i was just like man i
i am smart
i had a reply saying i expected more
from you yes
that they thought that at least i would
not would want to reject the hate
but that my need for hate is so great
that i won't correct greg gutfeld on the
5.
you know i'm going to from now on i'm
just doing nothing but fake yeah what
happens because this is going to be so
much fun it's like performance art they
do all the work for you all you got to
do is like throw a little pebble into
the lake and you just watch it all like
and you get a monologue and you get a
monologue on a friday i needed one too
my god slow news day hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else